for all the talk about CNN being a
left-wing biased fake news media outlet
they're really not acting like it on the
basis of recent decisions about 2020
election coverage we learned yesterday
that CNN has hired a total right-wing
hack to run their entire 2020 election
coverage her name is Sarah is gir she
will be shaping and directing the entire
presentation of the 20/20 election for
CNN you might be interested to know that
is gore previously referred to CNN as
the Clinton news network is gore was the
main spokesperson for Donald Trump's
attorney general Jeff Sessions she is no
journalism experience whatsoever her
experience is shilling for Jeff Sessions
and for Carly Fiorina and for Mitt
Romney and for Ted Cruz so let's break
this down piece by piece political
people like Sarah is gir leaving
administrations and then joining news
networks as pundits or as analysts or as
commentators it's very common it's very
cool as Trump would say it's really not
a big deal it's very common you know CNN
hired Corey Lewandowski and Obama
surrogate van Jones was hired by CNN and
okay it's fine but to hire a partisan
administration individual to join the
news network to direct news coverage is
not nearly as common and it is
extraordinarily concerning particularly
when so much of the right considers CNN
to be as I said left-wing fake news
let's look at a couple of choice tweets
from Sarah is Gore's past starting with
one where she said dear self-righteous
liberals every time you call all
Republicans evil stupid racist you are
no different than Trump you were the
problem bogus false claims about jobs
under Barack Obama that Sarah is Girt
tweeted remember this is the person
who's going to be directing CNN's 20/20
election coverage she said quote
hypocritical for Hillary Clinton to
pretend her policies don't hurt women
92% of jobs lost in Obama's first term
belonged to women that was obviously
untrue it should have been blatantly
untrue to her just doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
and then lastly here's a tweet from
Sarah is gir downplaying climate change
saying quote these are the same people
who think climate change is our biggest
national security threat
so no so the reason I see this Pat is
such a major misstep by CNN is that CNN
is already maligned by the right and by
Trump as catering to liberals being
liberally biased being anti Trump being
quote fake news they now decide to bring
on a hardcore extremist right winger
bond throwing right winger to run their
election coverage so they're going to
have it's sort of like the worst of both
worlds on the one hand the right already
doesn't care about CNN because Trump has
convinced them that is liberal fake news
and they're going to have a right winger
running their entire 2020 election
coverage just a totally boneheaded
decision by CNN do you think this is it
all analogous to Fox News having Shepard
Smith and Chris Wallace on their network
because those guys I wouldn't call them
left wingers but they're certainly to
the left of the majority Fox News
audience and maybe they do that so they
can provide a little bit of balance and
excuse themselves as not being pure
conservative propaganda is there any
similarity there with what CNN is doing
with this higher I don't think so I
don't think so because this is someone
who is directing the coverage behind the
scenes so it's not even public facing
where it gives CNN this ability to say
you might hear a lot of what sounds like
anti Trump stuff on some of our shows
but here is a different perspective on
the shows this is someone who's going to
be working in a much more private and
arguably sinister way in shaping
election coverage so the bottom line
here is what the bottom line is CNN care
about selling ads and making money just
like all of these other stations they
for whatever reason have made the
decision that their business priorities
are furthered by hiring Sarah is Gore a
right-wing Schilling bomb-throwing hack
who has worked exclusively to perpetuate
the propaganda of various right-wingers
including trump administration officials
and I guess they think that that's the
best thing to do in terms of their
business going forward so we'll be
watching it very closely and just
remember when they say on the right CNN
is left-wing fake news they have they
literally have put in place a right wing
propagandist a spokesperson for a number
of right-wingers to run their twenty
twenty election coverage so it is just
completely laughable to think that that
is the appropriate interpretation of
what it is that's happening on CNN at
this point today's show is made possible
in part by Sun basket giving everybody
in our audience 60% off their first box
when you go to get Sun basket calms
slash Pakman you'll get six dinners
delivered to your door for just twenty
eight dollars son basket is a meal kit
service that brings fresh ingredients
for ready to cook recipes to your home
but they are not like some of the other
companies that you might have heard
about because what makes Sun basket
different is their commitment to
sustainability which I know is really
important to lots of people in our
audience organic ingredients USDA
certified antibiotic hormone free meats
as well as an ability to accommodate
just about any type of diet if you are
low carb if you are gluten-free if you
are paleo vegetarian vegan pescetarian
Mediterranean Sun basket has you covered
or even if you're not sticking to a
particular type of diet Sun basket has a
lot of great plans to choose from
just pick a meal plan choose how many
recipes you want per week you can even
choose which recipes you want before you
get them so that you know you're getting
meals you'll enjoy and the list of
recipes changes every week you can also
choose when
meals show up at your home which is
really useful for me in particular you
can even skip weeks if you need to
everything that needs to stay cold stays
cold everything stays totally fresh all
the ingredients are pre measured which
makes everything really easy for you and
all of their packaging is recyclable and
compostable which I especially love
start getting sustainable delicious
healthy organic meals sent right to your
home and get a 60 percent discount off
your first week of meals just by going
to get Sun basket comm slash Pakman
you'll get six dinners delivered to your
door for just 28 bucks I've put the link
right underneath this video